here are some things North Korea doesn't
have a human rights record to speak of
political or economic freedoms or enough
food to feed its citizens here's what
North Korea does have a nuclear weapons
program and an unpredictable goong
leader whose finger is on the button our
North Korea's nuclear threat something
to fear were just saber rattling from an
isolated nation so here's the situation
on January 6 2016 a 5.1 magnitude
earthquake was detected here it was the
result of North Korea's fourth nuclear
test in a decade while military experts
are skeptical of Pyongyang's claim that
had detonated a full-fledged hydrogen
bomb they agree the test further north
korea's aim to mount a nuclear warhead
on a ballistic missile the united
nations and the u.s. once again
responded to the threat with even more
sanctions and we need to dial up our own
sanctions and toughen sanctions
enforcement and that's exactly what this
bill does from Kim il-sung to Kim Jong
ill to Kim jong-un north korea has been
ruled by a family of aggressive
dictators since nineteen forty eight
each intent on a nuclear strategy that's
deep into the nation's isolation which
is why the u.s. currently has nearly
30,000 troops stationed in South Korea
backed with firepower such as Apache
helicopters have 16 fighters and
nuclear-capable b-2 stealth bombers
based in the region now here is the
argument this could all just be a tactic
north korea has a long history of
escalating and then de-escalating
hostilities in order to broker economic
and diplomatic concessions south korea
would support from japan and other
nations will bear most of the cost of
providing North Korea was fuel to make
up for the nuclear energy it is losing
which leaves the US and the world in a
tricky position most diplomatic
situations call for a carrot stick
approach unfortunately with North Korea
neither the carrot in the form of aid
nor the stick in the form of sanctions
has worked with none of North Korea's
opponents willing to risk a military
pretation over the nuclear issue the
most realistic options are ever stronger
sanctions or just to wait for the
downfall of the Kim dynasty neither is
ideal especially when Kim's erratic
behavior including executing his own
uncle is added to the mix